like this place I mean I heard it was
paid but this is easy you can just drop
me off anywhere do I know you
I'm drew Hagel and I'm Shannon's dad who
the hell is that Jamie's girlfriend Oh
[Music]
okay well I wish it teaching we love you
no matter what
dad does not carry I'm Jamie's mother
nice to meet you
we love Shannon you've done well so real
estate agent I mean I thought that was a
job for divorced middle-aged housewives
[Music]
okay I ask you something yeah you know
invest in womv minimums three hundred
hundred thousand yeah nothing ventured
nothing gained right three affairs in 20
years I don't think that's so bad and
you're still with him
[Music]
now I'm gonna take you home
[Music]
did you drive drunk last night I don't
know maybe your car get here someone
drove me back from the party everybody
saw you with him at the party arguing
about his car keys the question is who's
gonna get in trouble for it not you ahem
your investment in the fund has gone
down I'm not built for this Quinn I'm
not like you I need that money back it
doesn't work like a game it is to you it
is a game you make that money in a week
clearly Jamie was driving the raglan did
you find one away from home what is here
I can't get involved in some kind of
conspiracy what do you want I want my
money back
guillotine guillotine
I can provide you information that will
save yourself that's worth something
[Music]
you